Lembra quando eu falava que vitamina D
não era só para osso? Pois é. Saiu agora
um estudo brasileiro bombástico,
mostrando que ela pode ser uma arma
poderosa contra o câncer de mama.
Pesquisadores da Unesp de Botucatu
pegaram 80 mulheres com câncer de mama
que iam fazer químio antes da cirurgia.
Metade tomou vitamina D, apenas 2.000
unidades por dia. A outra metade
placebo. 6 meses depois, qual foi o
resultado? Impressionante. No grupo da
vitamina D, 43% das mulheres tiveram
resposta completa a quimio, ou seja, o
tumor sumiu completamente nos exames. No
grupo placebo, só 24%, quase o dobro de
eficácia. E sabe por quê? A vitamina D
gruda direto nos receptores das células
cancerosas e manda elas pararem de se
multiplicar. É como se ela desligasse o
botão de crescimento do tumor, reduz
inflamação, impede invasão, controla
proliferação e, o melhor, com uma dose
segura, barata, sem efeitos colaterais.
Eu particularmente até aumentareia essa
dose em muitos casos específicos.